LAURENCE MORONEY:
Laurence Moroney
here on the Coffee With a
Googler stage on level two.
And I have a great
pleasure to chat
with David Burke
about Android M.
And hopefully
you've had a chance
to download the Android
M developer preview.
I took a look at it
last night, and I've
started calling it Android Mmm.
And so Dave, welcome
to the stage.
And thanks for joining us.
DAVID BURKE: Thank you.
Thanks for inviting me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I hear
we had a little bit of fun
last night, yesterday, with
the whole keynote and something
that was on your watch face.
DAVID BURKE: Yeah, so I'm
wearing this new Huawei Watch.
It's super nice.
And I decided I wanted to
hack up my own watch face.
And I was trying to
think what I should do.
So of course, people
speculated about what
the name of the new
dessert's going to be.
So what I did was I created
a watch face that basically
alternates all my favorite
desserts beginning with M.
It's very simple to code up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
should open source that.
DAVID BURKE: Indeed.
And then the actual doodles
were drawn by Dan Sandler.
Dan is a wizard at
creating amazing doodles.
He does all our Easter
eggs in Android.
So he literally whipped
up, like, seven or eight
desserts for me.
And then when I went on
stage, I decided, well,
I might as well put one
that's very easy to recognize
from a distance.
So I fixed it on Milkshake.
And then when I was handing over
to David Singleton, I was like,
and now I'd like to
welcome David Singleton up
to the stage to talk to
you about Android Wear.
And if you look at me, I'm kind
of, like, really pronounced.
So it worked out pretty well
because The Verge then picked
up on it and put it on Reddit.
And then Reddit just goes whoo.
And everyone's speculating.
It's like, oh, it's
going to be Milkshake,
it's going to be Milkshake.
And then I figured
I'd wait a little bit.
And then I posted on Twitter.
And I took multiple
shots of the watch.
You can see it's currently
on Marshmallow right now.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's Marshmallow.
OK, I was wondering.
DAVID BURKE: It's
Marshmallow, yeah.
Oh, and there's Malt Ball.
Or Malteser, as
we would call it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, I love Maltesers.
DAVID BURKE: And so then I
posted on Twitter, going,
rumors of Milkshake
are exaggerated.
It actually has all my
favorite M desserts.
My favorite tweet was somebody
went, troll level keynote.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hey,
if you're going to do it,
that's the place, right?
DAVID BURKE: I was
having some fun.
But it's great.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
One of the things
that struck me when you
were talking yesterday
about Android M was really
the focus on quality.
I have a Nexus 5, and I upgraded
it from KitKat to Lollipop
last year.
And I really like Lollipop.
And I'm, like,
surprised and impressed
that if we can have
even more quality.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about what you're
doing with that?
DAVID BURKE: The
way to think about M
is, well, first to
understand M, you sort of
have to think about
what was L, or Lollipop.
So with Lollipop, we had
literally the biggest release
we'd built since 1.0.
Massive changes, right?
So material design, which
is our new design language.
We had a 64-bit support.
We changed the run time.
We changed how parts of
the network stack work.
I mean, we went a
little bit crazy.
And then if that
wasn't enough, we then
did Android TV and Android
Auto and Android Wear.
So it was a very
big release for us.
We're super proud
of what we did.
But for M, what
we wanted to do is
we wanted to go back to the
core, go back to the basics,
and think about the
core user experience.
Just like all the little
things that we could do better.
And it's not really, bugs aside.
Of course, we're fixing bugs.
But it's more
about, let's rethink
how certain things have
worked since the beginning.
Can we make it better?
And if we do this
across the board,
can we really come up with a
very nice, polished release?
That's really what
M's about, basically.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, yeah.
I'm looking forward to it.
One of the
crowd-pleasers yesterday
was the volume control.
DAVID BURKE: Right.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I have to
say that is one of the things
that I'm really looking
forward to having improved.
DAVID BURKE: Yeah,
so I think we,
with Lollipop, we
over-rotated on flexibility
and probably made it a
little bit more complicated
than it should be.
So good news is
we simplified it,
and it works as you'd expect.
But we also then did
add a drop-down that
allows you to change the
stream volumes, which
is pretty handy because
often you'll want your media
volume different to
your alarm volume,
different to your earpiece
volume for a call.
So it's just a very
quick way of getting it,
but it doesn't overcomplicate.
So it was one of those examples
of a little thing we changed
that improves the experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Like when I'm
listening to music on my phone,
and then I get a hangouts ding.
And at the same volume.
It's like-- Right,
so it's good stuff.
Another really neat
thing that I saw
was, I'm calling it
granular app permissions.
I don't know what the
actual proper name is.
But like, the way
that you can actually,
first of all, on
demand have the app
permissions instead of up front.
And then also the user
can go in later on
and change all the permissions.
DAVID BURKE: Yeah, and I think
when Android started out,
we would ask for the permissions
up front before you install it.
I think if you look at what's
happened over the last seven
years or so since we first
launched the very first Android
device, mobile apps have gotten
more and more complicated.
They do more and more.
They're location aware and
user aware and what not.
And so as a result
you're seeing apps
with more and more permissions.
And so the problem with asking
all the permissions up front
is it's, as a user you start
getting a little jaded.
You're like, am I
even reading this?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There's a long list,
DAVID BURKE:
There's a long list.
How do I select the
things I do or don't want?
So we decided it was
time to rethink it.
And so now we have basically
two things we've done.
One is we've simplified
the set of permissions
to a smaller number of
easily understood things.
And we sort of re-architected
the platform around
that so they fit
into those buckets.
So things like microphone access
or camera access or location
access.
And then the second
thing we've done
is we now, rather than ask
for them at installation time,
we ask for them at run time,
when the app is actually
running.
And then we put a bunch of
thought into little details
like, if the app asks
and the user says
no, the second time if the app
asks, we're going to say never,
user gets a chance to
say, never ask again.
But we do that the second time
because what can sometimes
happen is the user
can accidentally
press the wrong thing.
Then the developer's stuck.
And so we put a bunch
of thought into it.
The other nice side
effect of it is
we've noticed that,
if you have an app
and you're updating
it on Play Store
and you needed to add a
permission because you're
adding a new feature.
Let's say you were
adding location awareness
to a traffic app or
something in a later release.
Well, you'd have location
at the beginning,
but let's just imagine.
What would happen is that the
update would require the user
to go into Play
Store and actually
say yes to the upgrade.
Now with the new
permission model,
it will just update
automatically.
And it's only when the user
goes to use the app does
the permission come up.
So it's better for the
developer, and it's better
for the user.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It makes more
sense when you think about it.
It's like it's
almost common sense.
And also like, sometimes
a bad experience.
Like I pick a new
app in the App Store,
and then it has this
100 permissions.
I don't even know what the app
does yet and I have to give it.
So I really like that update.
So it's pretty cool.
DAVID BURKE: The other
thing just to mention
is that you can also
go into the Settings
and you can actually turn
off permissions as well.
So after the fact.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly.
So if I don't like that I've
given this app permission,
I can change it.
That's really, really cool.
It certainly just makes
for a much friendlier user
experience, which is great.
Now one of the other things
that I really enjoyed
was the Doze, which
is a nice name.
Because I have exactly the
scenario that you mentioned.
I have a tablet, and I'll
sometimes leave the tablet.
And maybe I didn't
close the cover right
on the tablet or something like
that, and suddenly I come back,
and it's 20% battery left.
That kind of stuff.
So Doze is really cool for that.
DAVID BURKE: Yeah, it's
kind of trading off.
Android's pretty
amazing at that.
It's sort of almost
overoptimized in freshness.
Everything's always
the latest information.
But I think what we realized
was that, especially
for the tablet use cases, users
were actually willing to have,
it's OK if it's out of
date for, like, 10 seconds.
I'd rather that, but my
tablet lasts twice as long.
And so the idea with
Doze is basically
we use significant
motion detection
to detect if the device has
been left alone for a long time.
And then we start
exponentially backing off.
Basically it'll go asleep,
wake up for a little bit,
then it will go asleep for
a longer period of time,
wake up for a
little bit, and then
go asleep for a
longer period of time.
So it backs off.
And what that does is it reduces
the standby current that's
been drawn on the battery.
And so it will extend the
battery life significantly.
So we're seeing--
and we mentioned
this in the keynote-- we're
seeing up to two times
longer in standby if you
just leave the devices alone.
And so we're still
working on it, by the way.
That's the other
thing to remember.
This is a preview, really.
This is not launched.
And so we're still tweaking
and making it better.
But initial results are
looking really good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: For a preview
it still looks pretty good.
DAVID BURKE: Yeah,
we're pretty happy.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's kind of solid.
So it's cool.
So then one of the other
things you were talking about
was Type-C USB?
DAVID BURKE: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And we're beginning
to see that in lots
of places now, right?
DAVID BURKE: Yeah.
The number one,
actually, it think
it was like the
biggest cheer I got
was for not having to do this.
Which side is it?
So because USB Type-C,
of course, is flippable.
It's symmetric, right?
And so we've been working with a
bunch of manufacturers and sort
of helping this.
We actually had a lot
of people in Google work
on the standards for
USB Type-C. So it's
something we've been
very heavily involved
with from the very start.
And it's got a couple
other nice features.
You can run DisplayPort
over it for VideoEdge
if the device supports that.
You can charge
much more quickly.
So basically what you do, rather
than the old school USB being,
like, 5 volts and relatively
low current, now what you do
is you actually
step the voltage up.
And you have higher
current and voltage there
for higher powers.
You can charge more quickly.
Like up to three times
faster, which is pretty cool.
And then we had to do a
couple little tweaks to the OS
because you might have,
like, a phablet and a tablet.
And you plug them
into each other.
Who's charging who?
And so you can now choose the
direction of the current flows.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That was the thing.
I never even thought
of that scenario
where I could use my tablet
to charge my phone if I
need to make a phone call.
I was like, kind of cool.
Because I usually carry
one of those little battery
packs as well as my
tablet and my phone.
But now I can get rid
of that stuff I need to.
That's pretty cool stuff.
So much stuff that
you're announced.
And it's only a preview.
DAVID BURKE: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I'm sure there's
a whole lot more good stuff.
And I know we can't
talk about it now,
but I'd encourage folks to go
out and download the preview.
Have a play with it.
Download the SDKs when
they're available.
Have a play with
Developing for Android
M. And any last
messages on Android M?
Any last--
DAVID BURKE: No.
Please do exactly what you said.
Download it, try it out.
Find some bugs, file some bugs.
We want to fix as many
things as possible.
Try the new features.
And like you said, there's lots
of things we can talk about
that we've added.
Bluetooth stylus
support, MIDI support,
there's just a bunch
of really cool things.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There's MIDI support?
DAVID BURKE: MIDI support, yeah.
So you can plug
your drum kit in.
So rock out on M.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
So thanks very much, Dave.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching.
Go ahead, download
Android M Preview today.